from his humble roots and searchlight to
the spotlight of capitol hill
his entire life was defined by defying
long odds few have dedicated their lives
to the work of the people quite like
harry did
and today
our feelings of both loss
and gratitude
are immense
today former senator harry reid laid in
state at the u.s capitol rotunda one of
the highest honors our country can
bestow president biden and other leaders
gathering to pay their respects reed was
the longest serving senator in nevada
history when he retired back in 2017.
the late lawmaker is now making his way
back to the silver state reed's final
resting place will be in the town where
he was born the senator even showed the
exact grave site in searchlight nevada
to the i-team's george knapp more than a
decade ago
i'm feeling very well i
still going underground treatment which
i probably will for a long time in
multiple interviews over the past few
years we always ask senator harry reid
how he was feeling i feel pretty good
yeah considering he was typically candid
but never morose about his prospects for
survival georgie you
always remember i told you this before
you play the cards you're dealt after he
was diagnosed with pancreatic cancer in
may 2018 many including the new york
times assumed reed would be gone within
six months or so but he defied the odds
no surprise to those who knew him as
usual though reed was way ahead of the
curve in planning for his own death back
in 2006 reed invited us to visit a
graveyard i'm named after this guy here
this is mason reed and my middle name is
mason
he was killed as a young man down here
in a mine blew up a modest cemetery in
the hard scrabble town of searchlight is
the spot reed chose for his final
resting place
oh sure his parents are buried there
along with other family members and my
grandparents are buried here of
the course been here a long time
yeah
reed was born just a stone's throw from
the cemetery in a one-room shack with an
outhouse for a bathroom his
hard-drinking father was a miner his mom
did laundry for a local bordello reed is
not only part of searchlight's history
he literally wrote the book on it there
was never any doubt about where he
wanted to be buried the searchlight home
he built during his senate career was a
de facto read museum filled with items
that interested him come in the bathroom
now this is my prize
signed poster of the grateful dead
can it be true harry reid deadhead in
recent days senator reid has been lauded
by the nation's most powerful people in
searchlight he's remembered as the guy
they'd run into at the coffee shop
and to those who knew him best as far
back as his high school yearbook he's
remembered for his dry sly wit there it
is
most humorous harry reid
right next to the most attractive there
i am not so pretty but very funny george
knapp 8 news now
and following reed's retirement from the
senate a few years back our i-team put
together a special show about reed's
career and early beginnings in nevada
you can watch that on our website at
8newsnow.com